good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast
happy friday friday
gotta get down on friday
congratulations you made it to friday
it's a it was a rough one but we're here
it was the longest week like in the
history of america correct
i feel like they're having longer ones
but
this was a particularly long one it
literally never ended like every day i
woke up and i'm like it's friday yet and
it's like no it's just tuesday
also the fact that it was the week after
daylight savings waking up every day
this week was extra hard for me
and just also the week after a vacation
oh for you yeah
also to this morning though was easier
because bruce woke me up he came in
early he was like mom mom like this
guy's awake so i'm awake so we have to
play and i was like okay bruce i'm up
crazy old bruce uh but bruce is doing
well thank you everyone who's been
checking in on him
he um he's on day 10 of recovery so it's
all
it's all downhill from here you're being
really like um strict with the cone and
i just want to let you know like you can
take it off
the few times that he's had some free
time like i have seen him go to that
area so i'm just i don't want his shoes
i want bruce to be happy and healthy
on the loose and then eventually on the
loose that's fair
mm-hmm um so it's fine you got any big
weekend plans i do i'm actually going
away
so this would be a good time to tell
everyone that um next week's episodes
will be audio only
um i know like i can hear the the
audience when
but we told first of all literally
there's like the fact that we have this
whole studio set up when like they get
like 30 to 40 000 views like in the
grand scheme of our overall numbers like
it's nothing
i put like the the most um i feel like
the most active toasters like watch on
youtube so they're always like upset
when we're not in video
but most of our community listens as a
podcast um and this charade we put on
that's like literally our only cost of
like expense
it is what it is but for the most part
like but no but people really love the
youtube and and we love it too and
and so it is a bummer when we can't do
it but we will be audio only next week
and then we'll be back so
but we just had you guys we told you
guys after the when the vaccine comes
like
we are ripping it up like we are taking
life by the balls like i am traveling
i'm going to see the northern lights so
you know what i mean like i have things
planned and we will always have the
podcast
the video isn't promised yeah we but we
will always be available for you so next
week will be audio
only my apologies i've had this trip
planned for a while and i was just like
nervous to tell the group
only because we're coming off the heels
of like my trip yeah we should just like
synchronize our trips we were trying
i was trying to synchronize my trip with
yours it just didn't work out so that's
life
that's like life doesn't work out
sometimes and after a year of being
cooped up in months of doing zoom toast
like
we deserve it yeah no after like the
treachery that was
zoom [ __ ] toast um and people
keep asking like
well if you're gonna do podcast episodes
can you just upload the zoom to youtube
and like hypothetically
yes we could emotionally i don't think i
can sustain that kind of trauma
actually even the hypothetically so now
when we did zoom toast we
zoomed in we had better audio but now
when
we do remote episodes we facetime and
record our own audio so that the audio
is really good
so there's actually no visual recording
and that would have to be a separate
step that would compromise the audio and
our remote audio is at
such a good place it's literally better
than our regular show it's sickening
yeah
it is sickening so we've got a good
system
so all in all next week we will not be
in studio
yes and i had one other thought oh
speaking of just the past year zoomtoast
etc today we are doing
a patreon podcast episode a general q
and a emphasis on the queue because of
the one year anniversary of the queue so
it's all your questions about the past
year for us
people have been submitting great
questions if you want to hear the
episode when it drops patreon.com the
morning toast and if you're missing our
beautiful stunning and smart faces next
week you can always see them
on the patreon where we have premium
vlog content tonight i'm actually
shooting a vlog to go live next week i'm
really excited oh
your cooking vlog fabulous fabulous
fabulous
um well not that you asked but i have a
few things planned this weekend
um and i'm actually kind of worried
because i feel like this is probably the
most
jam-packed socially um
weekend i've had like in a while and i
don't know if i can like sustain like
i'm used to like literally sitting at
home all weekend
and i have three plans wow do you want
to share them friday night
saturday day and saturday night now of
course they're not as
you know labor-intensive as my old
weekends used to be but compared to what
we've done in the queue like
i don't know if i'm gonna make it to the
saturday night part i think i think that
you will i think that your
like our bodies find the energy that we
need it's you know
adrenaline and like you know when
mothers can lift cars
all of a sudden like i know you mean
that's you transitioning from saturday
day to night
i mean i will lift the car if need be
right i think your body will supply you
without adrenaline
okay well i'm honestly like i've been so
excited all week like about
my weekend plans because like i haven't
had plans but there's like a part of me
that has a pit i'm like really feeling
like i'm not gonna be able to give it my
all at each event
just listen to your body the truckers
for my weekend have arrived and they
said claudia you can do it it's truckers
for adrenaline and they're like you
could even lift this truck
the druggers for adrenaline um also
well we have a fabulous show but last
night was the premiere of keeping up
with the kardashians the final season
i assume you watched i watch i had a
really premium watching experience
it was the opposite of every other show
that i watched where it's like if any
one single thing happened like i paused
yeah i needed to hear every single thing
like no time on my phone bruno and i
like i made big rigatonis oh my god i
had like a fabulous dinner while
watching as well
and it was just so premium but it was
also like hurting my heart
oh my god there's like a police do you
think there's drama outside like i heard
there's
always drama outside i know i literally
hate the city like more than anything
it's like why can't we just have a
normal shower like someone has to be
getting arrested outside like yeah
that's new york someone's getting pulled
over but they won't stop hashtag new
york strong
um so we will recap that in addition to
the fast five stories
um we've got some good stories today
yesterday was
it was a hard day for the stories no but
like i i personally like when the
stories are out of the box like
i think that that's like in yesterday's
episode was so funny because we're using
like pockets of our brain that we don't
normally use that's true as opposed to
talking about the same five people
um before we dive in i wanted to tell
you i watched the college admissions
netflix documentary and i first thought
i clicked on the wrong thing because
it's like a dramatized lifetime movie
version of what went down
spliced in with the documentary and at
first i was really not into it then i
kind of liked it
um and i learned a few things that i
thought were really interesting
of course like for the most part
everyone knows like the gist of what
went down
but i was really curious on the
logistics of like
how he called it like the side door how
he would get people into schools and
they just really explained like
the specific people at schools who were
um taking bribes personally and i feel
like the documentary did a good job of
highlighting a few things
one this guy john who was like honestly
one of the biggest victims like he
is a felon now and he was on house
arrest and like he just like
accidentally got caught up in this whole
thing and he never once
personally benefited like every time
rick singer would like try and bribe him
he just like gave the money to the
school like he thought he was
part of their job as fundraising and he
thought he was like fundraising for the
school
so the fact that like he became a felon
when like i think he was just like kind
of like dopey and like not
plugged like what was going on around
him i felt really really bad for him
and like when he was saying all like
when it all came out like his social
media he'd like
he never like thought of his social
media once but it was like public
and he was like saying like people were
like calling his house sending death
threats calling him like a big fat [ __ ]
like it was so
sad like and he was like when he was
he was just like like kind of pathetic
like i really really fell for felt for
him
the other thing i thought they did a
good job in was like really highlighting
the people who were involved like of
course you know felicity huffman lori
lachlan
felicity hoffman was barely in it and
laurie lachlan's story was in it because
um of course because of the olivia jade
of it all but like part of like the
the break in their system started when
olivia jade got into usc like
it was just like a red flag because her
um
application got flagged but obviously
the whole thing came down when like some
random guy got investigated for
securities fraud
and decided to this story instead no
sold out this yale coach who's accepting
and then the yale coach
sent him over to the big guy rick singer
now the this is where it was frustrating
and one more interesting factoid that i
feel like they had like all they had
been
tapping rick's phone for like over a
year so they had crazy conversations in
the whole movie every conversation in
the movie
was a recreation of an actual
conversation that happened okay
um and for the most part like every
single parent
was doing this behind their kids back
like they were they
yeah because it's like you don't want to
tell your kid like you're a failure and
you can't get in on your own here like
right
so i thought it was really interesting
how like they weren't even worried about
getting caught they were worried about
getting caught by their kids that's
crazy which was crazy
um the other thing that i oh that was so
disappointing is like
so rick singer gets caught and
instead of going to jail he decides to
comply
to sing like a bird sang like literally
called every single person
spoke so specifically like so yeah
remember when i had that guy
judo take that test for your kid andrea
like these parents were so stupid like
he was being so obvious
um but he is a waiting sentence he pled
not guilty because he took a deal for
whatever so he's still a free man when
like all these other parents who like
did wrong too but like he was literally
like the mastermind he's not in jail and
he can't be sentenced until
every single one of the cases of the
people
who he sold out is sentenced and that'll
be like
years that is so [ __ ] so [ __ ] and
the other [ __ ] up part that they made
a really good point at the end of the
documentary was like
this is the only like racketeering
bribing um
scandal where the victims were like
stanford
a billion dollar institution and at the
end of the day they were the victim and
they accepted over seven hundred
thousand dollars
in donations that they claim they've
given to philanthropic organizations
which is like such a lie
um so of course like we focus on like
the parts
that like upset us most which is like
the privilege and at the end of the day
they made a good point it's like
the sats in the college system is
designed to benefit
wealthy people like wealthy people who
grew up in rich families are
statistically better to do
statistically proven to do better on the
sats it's a test made for
people who can afford 400 an hour tutors
so like you're already at such an
advantage
that you're going to cheat like it just
makes it so much worse so like
that's that's what people are focused on
like the privilege of it all but there's
also like a lot of other elements of the
college admission scandal that are so
[ __ ] up
like the whole college process and it's
like why are we as there's over three
thousand colleges in america like
why are we so obsessed with like 20 of
them and not only did the college
admission scandal benefit the schools
for making 700 000
they're now even more prestigious like
look at the lengths all these wealthy
people are willing to go
to prison for their kids it only makes
these schools even more exclusive
that's so interesting because my
takeaway from the scandal is like a lot
of these schools have
it especially like usc feels really
illegitimate and it's like
it's not a huge accomplishment for one
to have gone there that's what like
that's how what it feels well but i
guess other people have another takeaway
and i also agree with you and i had this
thought um a few months ago when we were
talking about olivia jade again where
it's like
yes we focus on like the celebrity
aspect you know the privilege what we
can
see exactly but like the whole college
admissions process
is so [ __ ] up and like we talk about
how you know you can donate a library
and that's legal but you pay off a
soccer coach and that's illegal it's
just much cheaper
but like the fact that you can donate a
lot like all of these tiers of
advantages
are so [ __ ] up and so unfair and the
fact that there's a legal way to buy
your way
into a school is also [ __ ] up yeah and
so that's what rick's whole policy was
he was like
you can go through the front door which
is applying like everyone else
the back door which is the legal way of
buying a building but that like they
have requirements some of these schools
of like 10 million dollars
or the side door which is like getting
on a small
sports team like rowing like sailing um
so he had this
like this illegal way of buying your way
into schools but the fact is
there's still a very legal way of doing
it and a lot of these schools
are like super corrupt and like they are
also the point that's the point like of
course
what those parents did was wrong 100 i'm
not saying not that but i think there's
more than one conversation to be had
about the college admissions scandal
and honestly the documented documentary
was giving me
the worst anxiety about when i have kids
and like sending them to school like
because it's so traumatic on the kids
like they put all their self-worth into
getting into certain schools
and when they don't like it just
completely destroys them and you really
feel like in order to make it in life
like you have to go to a specific
college
when at the end of the day like it
literally has no bearing on your future
at all like get an education anywhere
like that's not even what matters
the name of where you go i agree but so
it just left me like
parents who put that pressure on their
kids well that was the other thing it's
like so many of people's parents
either like our immigrants or didn't get
to go to college themselves so they're
going through this college process with
their kids like as if it's for
themselves
yeah so it's just really toxic
um and i just thought the documentary
did a good job of highlighting obviously
like the glamorous like celebrity
element
which is what made it such a big story
but there's more to it than that like
it's
there's so many things that you could
take away from the the varsity blues
thing that like i never even thought of
which is like these universities that
are like worth billions of dollars
except millions of dollars in donations
like they were the victims here which is
like
lol lol the victims were like the spots
taking place that they took from other
serving hard-working children
yes yes i i thought about watching the
documentary maybe i will since it sounds
like
it was just something i just feel like
i'm kind of
over saturated on the college admission
scandal content i feel the same way
about
anna delvey like i watched the american
great episode i read every story i got
the point if there's new information
well maybe i'll check it out i even
watched like part of the actual lifetime
movie about the college admissions
skills oh that's
so bad yeah that's stupid i really i
just feel like
i heard most of it already see like i
didn't do that much research like i just
like knew about like the celebrity stuff
i didn't even know
like i didn't even know how they were
getting into school like i didn't know
anything
so if you don't if you only know like
what the news is telling you like olivia
jade felicity huffman
then it's actually quite informative
because i never really read in depth i
was just obsessed with like the
celebrity part of it like a normal
person
got it no the american greed episode
they did covered all that it was good it
was an hour and 40 minutes like a great
way to
you know wait for ben to come home you
know yes that is a great way that's
literally my life i have so much stuff i
want to watch on netflix but i'm really
trying to cut back on tv and because i
watched kardashians last night like that
was my tv for the night what else are
you
like waiting to watch um the new roseman
pike movie what's it called
i forget but what i care a lot
apparently it's so good
what's it about i don't know and i don't
want to know but it's just apparently
good i also well yesterday i guess i was
like really bored i finished the
mother-in-law
and i just like absolutely loved it like
i never i didn't expect
to like like a book like that it's not
something i would normally like but it
was
so like emo really got me in my feels i
cried twice wow
it's crazy that you liked it so much i
recommended it because i figured you
would enjoy it somewhat but i actually
didn't even love it that much so you
liked it way more than i did i feel like
when it comes to books i'll either scale
them on at a like as a four or a five
because if it's anything less i won't
finish it so i gave this one a four
i think the books that i've read in the
last year that i would give a five are
like the best of the best like
uh luckiest girl alive evelyn hugo
maybe that's it like yeah and all the
other ones that are good but
there are no fives like five is like i
would read this again
and recommend to everyone right four is
like i very much enjoyed my time with
this book
for me three is good book three i would
i would never finish
for me two is i wish i never bought the
book because now i feel like you finish
it too
i just finished it too oh and then for
me
i finished a one for me once because it
was came
so highly recommended like it was on
every list and everything so i was like
i need to
it was also kind of like a mystery so i
just want to figure out what it is and
then i'll make my decision
actually i guess it's not true i've
finished some threes american royals
was a piece of [ __ ] um and i know this
is a hot take
daisy jones and the [ __ ] six i
know that's your favorite book
a literal piece of [ __ ] like i'm reading
this i'm like this is what my generation
likes
i can't i i was like this is trash
yeah and some people didn't like evelyn
hugo you didn't like
that's crazy to me because like i cannot
listen to taylor swift's ever more album
without feeling like i'm literally in
like 1960s hollywood like
champagne problems is celia and evelyn
like you cannot convince me otherwise
it's possible it definitely is taylor
definitely read that book speaking of
books i started a new book last night
because i had just watched victoria
um on amazon and i was just really
interested
in her and someone recommended this book
to me about her matchmaking so
she had like uh i don't know maybe eight
or nine children
and then over 40 grandchildren and she
made matches for all of her children and
grandchildren
so at one point they were sitting on
every throne in europe her entire
life for that yes so the book is about
like
that's pretty cool the history and how
she made like why she made certain
matches
so i'm enjoying it i read the sample
last night that's my new thing i try the
sample
if i it's like 10 of the book if i like
it i buy the book so i bought the book
okay so that's what we've been up to
yeah i have a lot on my want to read
list like so i i
really want to get through some reading
but because i'm going on a trip i think
i'm going to
you're going to bang it out mm-hmm i'll
let you know if i have any more
recommendations well i need another
recommendation but like i said i have a
bender plan this weekend so i don't
think there'll be a lot of time for
reading
no but i will work on my next
recommendation thank you
so i guess without further ado it could
be time i could guess i guess i could
wax poetic i could have breast without
the
other books i could keep you aggressive
you could but i think we should dive in
i think we should i think we have a lot
to talk about in the past five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
and we have a brand new sponsor today
that i feel like is really
perfect because we've been super focused
in this last year on like cultivating
vibes
and who would you say is like the queen
of cultivating vibes because i would say
it's one martha stewart
the queen the absolute queen so we are
here to introduce to you martha stewart
and marley spoon
the meal kit delivery that is a curated
variety of chef designed recipes by
america's
most trusted home chef martha stewart
um so martha stewart and marley spoon
make great tasting meals possible every
day of the week
by delivering a variety of recipe
options ranging from breakfast to dinner
to desserts
their meals feature both the classic
flavors you love plus
new and exciting flavors you'll want to
discover all they have an all new menu
of 29 deliciously different recipes
every week
and all recipes can have just six simple
steps and 10 ingredients
and they can be prepared in just 30
minutes
ordering for marley spoon is really easy
and it removes the burden of grocery
shopping and meal planning which as we
talk about all the time
is super treacherous your order can be
customized every week to suit your
tastes and special diets
you can also skip or pause deliveries
anytime
so we were just talking about this i got
my marley spoon delivery this week and i
made um
salmon i i'm not gonna pronounce it
correctly but it was like with capers
and lemon and there were snappees and
string beans and it was so
good and i felt like martha stewart in
my home and it was such
a premium wonderful experience the
ingredients were so fresh
perfectly portioned so that is so
helpful in terms of waste
yes there is none and it was so
delicious and i literally
i felt like martha stewart and i feel
like what when one goes into the kitchen
you're always striving
to emulate miss martha stewart you are
and now she's literally giving you the
kit
to do it she gave you the case to the
kingdom and sometimes it's just like so
hard deciding what you want for dinner
but when you have like meals just
prepped like
you okay should i have the salmon or the
chicken tonight like it really narrows
down for you oh and the meal choices on
the website were so sick and easily
stunning there's chicken and broccoli
this pizza that looks so good i'm so
excited to make it
so if you're tired of the same old same
old go to marleyspoon.com for a variety
of chef design dinners
from martha stewart and the morning
toast listeners can save a hundred
dollars
over your first four orders and get free
shipping on the first delivery
but you gotta use code toast again
that's code t-o-a-s-t
at marleyspoon.com marley is spelled
m-a-r-l-e-y
spoon dot com code toast imagine eating
deliciously different chef quality meals
every day of the week martha stewart and
marley spoon makes it possible
go to marleyspoon.com today and again
code toast to save a hundred dollars
okay before we begin i think i have to
take my headband off because it's
starting to give me a headache and it's
just not worth it you guys all saw it it
was here this was actually a birthday
gift from olivia
um and i haven't been able to like wear
i feel like every time i wear it i look
a little stupid but it's mad tight yo oh
it looks cute on you does it oh my god
it looks so cute and especially with the
mc plant
oh my god it's literally so tight like i
don't know how you wore it for what have
we been live for like 15 minutes
yeah and even i wore it like at home too
okay so it looks really cute on you
while i thought maybe i think i feel
like you're wearing it right i feel like
when i was wearing it i look like
it actually does look cute yeah wears on
this wait until i can yeah until i can't
know more
okay first story of the day army hammer
has been accused of violently
violently raping a woman named effie
actor armie hammer was accused thursday
of violently raping an ex-girlfriend
who claims he abused her mentally
emotionally and sexually during their
four-year relationship
the woman who only gave her first name
is effie as she sobbed
and sobbed as she talks said that she
feared for her life throughout her time
with hammer
who has been accused by other women of
being into cannibalistic fantasies
quote he became increasingly more
violent i thought he was going to kill
me
she spoke alongside attorney gloria
allred on thursday
and said that the star's alleged abuse
escalated to rape on april 24th 2017
when she was 20 years old
the now 24 year old said that during the
attack he repeatedly slammed her face
against the wall
and left her bruised she said that the
abuse at the
at the hands of the actor whom she first
met on facebook led her to consider
suicide the lapd is now has an open
investigation
into army hammer um and this is just
atrocious atrocious oh my god honestly
like when this for all this stuff first
came out about army hammer like at first
when it was just like he wanted to eat
people's toes it was like everyone was
like like it was like funny
and literally with every piece of
information we get it is so not funny
it's so attractive
abhorrent and it's like the people
coming out
like it just doesn't end it's like one
after the other yeah and it's like now
nothing even surprises me like this is
horrible this is horrible i agree in the
beginning it was just like
cannibal the insecure like everyone was
just joking about it because it's a
cannibalism what the [ __ ] yes but i also
feel like and i think we mentioned this
on the show that like
there has been whispers that like a
bigger story was going to come and come
out about him i'm assuming that this one
is it
maybe also the time i had read like the
time of their relationship was while he
was married
oh right no it's like the list of
offenses just keeps going keeps going
so i literally hate this man so much
like and i
i'm really proud that i was never one of
those like army stands
yeah but i also like don't put it past
hollywood to find a way to rehabilitate
him
like i i honestly yeah i mean if mel
gibson
can work like anything is possible so i
just i
i really really hope i i really hope
like now
in the last three years time's up me too
like hollywood claims to have been
you know purged of all these terrible
people and
i i will be so disappointed if like this
isn't the end of army hammer
yeah publicly yeah no i agree so we'll
see
that's crazy i don't think so like i i
mean i mean when you think about how
many
horrible people there are walking around
hollywood who have yet to be like
quote-unquote exposed to have abused
their power abused women like
it's sick yeah so i you can't put
anything past hollywood
but this has been so public like people
have been following this story
and it just it keeps it never [ __ ]
ends like every every week i think we're
done talking about army hammer
something else he did like comes out so
i really hope
that you're not right i hope i'm not
ready to
uh we'll keep you posted on the
developing investigation and story
yes um next story some sad news tinsley
and scott have ended their engagement
this is [ __ ] crazy this is crazy
like she literally like gave up her life
her city
her everything for this man and we were
all like yes
and it never even occurred to me that
the two could even break up because to
me when you end that way i never even
it never even popped into my mind as
even a remote possibility yeah
scott told people in a statement after
14 months of engagement tinsley and i
have ended our relationship
and we have been living independently
for the last few months this was an
incredibly difficult decision but it is
one that i believe is best for both of
us i will always care about tinsley and
i
see sincerely wish her happiness and
success in all that she does in the
future
one weird that the non-celebrity partner
is putting out a statement to people
because i believe he's also the one who
broke up with her
well i i would think that too and now i
had read some stuff i think was like on
dumois
about um how they had like been it would
be like on and off for a while now that
he has a girlfriend
and that tins had like finally had
enough and
the thing is it's like what we've known
about scott since we met him is like
he's very commitment phobic like that
was always their problem
and then he committed right and so
that's never a way did he there's never
a way you want a commitment like
after years of begging you know yeah so
i'm really sad for tinsley and i feel
like she
probably will try to come back to
housewives
like with her tail between her legs no
please let her in i can't deal with like
an even so the first time she came to
housewives like
she was coming off this trespassing
charge in palm beach now she comes back
after being left at the altar like
i can't her her whole pathetic like
persona
she really got strong after her first
few seasons and i was like here for her
but now she's been like beat down again
and i cannot deal with like her coming
back like
with her mom and her daughter what if
she comes back in a strong way
i just don't see that for her okay but
like what if she could do it
i'm really over her like i was i was
happy to like let her okay
if you love something set it free if it
comes back
send it back home set it free send it
back to chicago um apparently a source
close to her said this was not mutual
she was blindsided she's on the floor
heartbroken and devastated
only imagine she was on the floor when
he came to surprise her in new york and
that was a good thing
so she's heartbroken and devastated and
i would add remiss
and she's on the floor you gotta get it
get yourself on the floor
i hope she's listening to that jlo and
pitbull song
that's like a weird detail to add from
thesaurus she's on the floor
she left everything for him because she
didn't think he'd ever call off the
engagement she trusted him that this
time was going to be different
i didn't think that either like that he
would ever
i just but now in hindsight it's like
it's not that shocking but i just
never it never even occurred to me no
that they could not work out it's so
hurtful
it was a fairytale ending fairy tales
don't end in a broken engagement they
end with you know
a castle and a prince right and a
wedding
so i guess the fairy tale continues
tints on the quest
yeah i feel like this is also like a bad
message to sound like a lot of people
like feel like saw themselves in tinsley
as like waiting for their happy ending
i think i think them getting together
was that like
them ending up together was the bad
message because it gives so many people
like
hope that like men will change right
stick around
right you know when you have and then
not they don't change and this is proof
and so i think this is a a better more
realistic message
unfortunately because like i really i
really feel like i'm an optimist and
when tins went to chicago i went to
chicago and you were like
really really happy for you were like
this is literally a fairy tale like i
didn't see it that way but after
speaking to you i'm like no it is a
fairy tale
and i'm just so mad at scott that he
made me look stupid yeah big time
not funny very sad um honestly like the
real housewives of new york is so
run down like the last season was such
trash like by the time
you know the episode and the season
ended like
dorinda was gone everyone was gone and i
don't know if tinsley coming back could
make it
even better or even worse like there's
really no way of knowing i just really
like tinsley and leah's friendship and i
think that like
the two of them doing their thing i mean
they do
bring down like the average age of the
group which is like always
keeps it fresh yeah but their real
housewives of new york is getting to
that oc place where it's almost
irreparable
oh okay dramatic no i'm just serious we
they just filmed a new season we haven't
even seen it yet no i'm only speaking
from the most recent season that i saw
like a normal person
no but like all of those women are
really like even though it got to a dark
place like those women are icons so
there's something
we can make something here we can oc i
don't
not icons no no no no no um okay ready
for our next choice more couple news
j-lo and a-rod can't stop kissing after
their breakup i'm like getting
i'm getting to a place where i might
want to keep china these two like i know
they
are so fatigued they put on a pda pack
display in the dominican republic
while meeting with their team and being
coincidentally photographed by paparazzi
well the thing is like everyone's
talking about their breakup when at the
end of the day
all we've heard from them is that
they're not broken up they're just like
taking time off so like ever they're no
but they're not taking time right the
media is like really sensationalizing
this like i feel like they've been
like pretty upfront with us you know you
think kind of but like where did that
thing come from that they were broken up
i don't know
and then the next day we're not like so
confirmed widely reported by everyone on
on planet earth and then they're like no
no we're not working up we're just like
spending time apart
yeah but i just feel like until i saw
this
like pr stunt i was like okay maybe we
they got it wrong
but now i'm like oh they have something
to prove they yeah i mean they
definitely called the
perhaps on themselves yes for sure yeah
and you only do that when you have
something to prove
so it just makes you question it makes
you question everything
but again um i was so
like the captain of this next time
scott okay i was the captain of this
particular ship and not only
am i like a deckhand now i'm secretly
sabotaging the ship
i'm literally like clogging portholes so
that the ship sinks
i'm squeegee girl who does both sides
yes you are what are you drinking there
i'm having some dry mouth
it's coffee um i ran out of paper cups
so i had to use this it's hot it's weird
to be
hot no it's not it's it's not like
scalding no it's hot coffee it's not
iced
yeah it's just sick it's weird no but no
i'm not drinking that [ __ ] it's because
i ran out of cups
well honestly and yesterday i ran out of
cups so i didn't bring my second coffee
with me
and you could tell yeah you were
fatigued all over me much like i
am with this story also just a little
fun fact about me
um i don't know if you know but like for
the last week i've been drinking coffee
every morning
what kind well it's mostly half and half
with a splash of coffee and a splenda
what's the coffee the starbucks medium
roast like that you get from the grocery
store it's like a big
um jug and how do you feel um i don't
feel any different because i
always just like i'm exuding energy i'm
like so naturally energized and
caffeinated
but it's like a delicious thing to drink
in the morning like i'm always so
thirsty and like sometimes water doesn't
do it you know
i mean that's not surprising for you
yeah most times most times
and sometimes it's just like really not
an appropriate hour to crack open a diet
pepsi right
so i have found this like little and i
just like like waking up and like having
like something to do
do you know what i mean yeah no i know
what you mean and it's a good i feel
like we've had this conversation like
it's a good delineation between like
sleep
and awake oh that's what it is yeah
so i mean i'll probably like do this
until i run out and like the jug's
almost done and like
now i just don't i don't need another
thing to purchase like another jug i
already
have two big jugs but i already have
like things i have to do every week like
manicure
lip wags you know like i just don't need
like another thing to do every day
really or like no i don't need another
thing to buy every week
what do you mean you get groceries you
get them with your friends barely so
what do you eat
look at me nothing no it's just like
it's gonna have to become a part of my
daily and weekly routine to purchase the
coffee to remember to drink the coffee
so while now i think teens are good
i don't disagree so we'll see we'll see
where this journey takes me i just
wanted to update everyone that like for
the first time in my life i've drank
coffee like four days in a row that's
crazy
we love to see it today i didn't like to
finish the whole thing because i was
like over it but you know what i mean
i do are you ready for our next story
i'm
ready come here find me
tic toc's addison rice surprises fans
with a debut single called
obsessed on friday the social media
today the social media star surprised
her fans with her debut single called
obsessed a
a catchy dance pop track all about
self love in the upbeat song the tick
tock star sings about loving herself
with lyrics like
when you say that you're obsessed with
me
too she says i'm obsessed with me
as much as you hey
say that you'd die for me i'd die for me
too okay so let's talk about it and if i
lost you
i'd keep so happy i can't lose i've only
keep going that no those are the legs
that they shared i've only listened to
it twice so i don't have it memorized
but it
is good i have a few thoughts and i
think we should talk about this in
multiple
stages yes let's tackle first what you
thought of the
song itself and the music video and her
performance
okay i thought the song itself was all
right i could see it growing on me
it was an interesting like first choice
of song it reminded me of meghan trainor
if i was you i'd want to be me too
that's true um and so i thought it was
cute i watched the video
thought it was cute but i'm officially
getting a headache
yep that'll do it um i was just thinking
more holistically because i saw this
morning like
posted hold on because i want to say one
thing okay what did you think of the
song
the song is trash the music video was
like whatever
but i did think it was a really
interesting insight and because i've
always felt this way like
not always like since i met addison like
a year ago um and i didn't meet her like
i meant like
i was introduced to her no no not even
though like i found out about her
you followed her yeah thank you um and
i've felt this way like ever since then
it's like
homegirl was really like meant to be
famous like she just nails being a
kardashian she nails being a tick tocker
she knows being an instagramer
and in the music video i'm like oh she
nails being a pop star like her
mannerisms her like lips you lip sync in
a music video
i just thought she nailed it from like a
performance standpoint like and i just
think like everything she does i'm
actually really excited now for he's all
that like
i haven't seen her do one thing that she
isn't good at right so this is what i
was going to say about her idea to
become
a singer like i believe that addison ray
can achieve whatever she sets her mind
to i think
she has it she has i t the x factor
and i'm just interested that now she
wants to be
a singer when like she is also on the
way to being a movie star she's also a
beauty star like
she's literally going to do everything
yeah and so like for me whenever we talk
about her
business ventures i really feel and i
hate to compare her to charlie demilio
but like they really came up together
i've really felt since the beginning
that like whoever is managing and
guiding addison is doing an amazing job
like
i've not questioned one of her
business ventures when i've questioned
like almost every single one of charlie
it's like her and dixie's starting a
ring light company like that makes no
[ __ ] sense to me like
100 million followers like that's what
you're doing like that it just made no
sense you know
so this is just the first time i've kind
of like cocked my head a little bit and
been like
what with the whole music thing i think
addison
is gearing up for a global takeover like
me too
and like she already is a famous dancer
and
a star so like why not an actress so why
not be
singing acting dancing well here's the
threat
that's a good question and begs the most
obvious question like
can she say and i don't know because you
can't tell until
she's performing on fallon tonight wow
so we will find out we'll see how she is
as a performer
i should have an ashley simpson
lip-syncing moment i just think that she
is a star is a star and she can do
whatever she decides to do she's going
to have success with it i really do
i agree with that and i feel i like i
love her like i'm a
huge huge fan of hers mostly because
like i find i've just
found it so interesting over the last
year to see what she's done
and accomplished with her fame and like
this is her and charlie are like
unprecedented there's never been
tick-tockers with this many followers
and
they're becoming like traditional
celebrities like addison is just as
famous as
whoever you know like a kaya gerber like
they're really just as like well-known
and i i love watching addison because if
i was in her position and i felt like i
had the star quality like i would have
done everything she did like i think
her manager her agent whoever it is like
it's just nailing it right
so i have to trust this process
everything that everything she does
she does in a very quality way it's not
like half-assed
it was high production the music video
yeah but then it also begs the question
like dixie dimlio has kind of cornered
this um
tick-tock pop star thing like her song
be happy which a lot of people made fun
of before they heard it and then it was
like literally a banger and it's so good
then she had another song that like i
didn't really um know much about
but that kind of seems like it's dixie's
thing like but or maybe like the next
generation of pop stars you have to be a
famous tick tocker first like that's how
you get in the door i could see that
being
like the reality you know because like
if you want a popular song that's where
you prove yourself
and it's so popular with music if you
want to have a popular song
you have to go viral on tick tock not
you like your song right so instead of
like working with artists to popularize
their song why not promote your own why
not do the whole thing
yeah no it's really like becoming like a
she's like a full-blown media company
yes and so even though the song like
it's no driver's license
um it's good enough that i'll be
listening to the next one too
yeah i mean i just like addison writes
like i'll watch whatever she does i'm
actually
jazzed about he's all that i know
anytime
it's gonna be on netflix it's gonna be
on netflix so very exciting we'll be
watching it there our fifth and final
story i have to pull up from my phone
cause it's a screenshot of forbes being
salty as
[ __ ] what are they reneging on there
kanye west six billion
okay so it was based on a ubs
bank evaluation that bloomberg and as we
said people magazine reported i did
i didn't quake at the name people
magazine but bloomberg gives it
levity but salty ass storms is saying
no kanye is not the richest black person
in america on wednesday multiple outlets
reported that west is
the richest black person in america
worth as much as 6.6 billion dollars
the news comes after bloomberg reported
that his sneaker brand yeezy as well as
easy gap which has yet to sell one item
of clothing have a combined value they
are so salty so angry
they hate the kardashians that they put
kylie on the cover one time and they
couldn't handle the
blowback of self-made yeah and now they
have to burn everything in their path
100 they're just like so angry they're
so [ __ ] like we finished reading
yep the combined value of as much as 4.7
billion the publication mentioned
without going into full detail and
an additional 1.7 billion in assets it's
not true based on our calculations
forbes estimates he's worth less than a
third of that or 1.8 billion dollars
that's a big jump from last may when
forums
first pegged his net worth to be 1.3
billion but nowhere near as much as the
purported 6.6 billion dollars
this to equities robert f smith remains
the richest black person in the us
we're always talking about robert smith
i live for him and he's worth an
estimated
6 billion okay let me just say something
for a while i would have went to forbes
as like the leading business celebrity
net worth publication but in the last
year they've made it very clear they
have this like hard-on for the
kardashians like
always coming after them and and like
i don't know ever since i found out that
like you literally have to apply to be
forbes 30 under 30 and you don't just
like get it because you're
a person under 30 who's powerful they
don't just like look at the landscape
and choose the powerful people
you have to write a whole essay on why
you think like it's and then you have to
have like a pr
agent like for you so ever since i've
like learned about the facade that it's
forbes like i don't really trust him
anymore and bloomberg is
legit like i don't think mayor former
mayor michael bloomberg would be too
pleased to hear about this
no i don't think he would i think
bloomberg ate these
eggs um that is just like such a nice
joke that maybe we should
explain yeah because it's not a joke
it's not camp rock no it's it's jessica
simpson right and we changed it
right okay so here's the joke so you
know in you probably don't
in camp rock remember how they used to
say jessica simpson went to the camp and
gave rock
so one of michi's friends is like no it
wasn't much friends she was in the
popular group yeah and she was one of
tessa's
clear she was not she was one of tessa's
backup dancers and
she had too cool you know
too cool you're doing it good like your
[ __ ] shoulder's going wild do you
think i could be
her shoulder was out of control tests
okay okay so they would say jessica
simpson went to the camp and one of um
tess's friends who was like the ditsy
dumb girl she was eating her eggs and
she was like
so you're saying jessica simpson ate
these eggs so
we used to go to a diner on 78th and
madison right by our high school
called beyond and their claim to fame is
that mayor bloomberg would have
breakfast
he lives on the upper east side i
believe them i believe it was mayor
bloomberg's breakfast spot of choice so
we would sit there and we would go
seriously
so you're saying mayor bloomberg ate
these eggs so i guess i didn't realize
it's not like a public joke like that's
a family joke
um but i think like everyone can relate
to themselves
to like i'm sure that jessica sims and
mine stuck out to others too
so if you ever find yourself somewhere
where a celebrity has been serious
addison ray ate these eggs well that's
what we were saying um
mayor bloomberg is just vomiting like no
i just think that forbes has seriously
and completely disgrace themselves and
like okay so you're upset that you
called herself made and you got all this
backlash whatever but like
and ever since they've just done
everything in their power like discredit
the kardashian businesses and i just
feel like in 2021 like we have to all
come together as a society and first
apologize to the kardashians for like
always making fun of them and to start
taking them seriously as business women
but the amount of like personality in
that caption of like
angry
it's just like forbes you're supposed to
be above these things yeah no it's like
forbes you're showing your bias
yeah your bias is showing so um
i'm sticking with bloomberg's valuation
um i'm sure
the truth is somewhere in the middle as
it usually is yeah that's fair so
forbes too salty um well speaking of the
kardashians that's a great segue into
last night's episode
the premiere episode of the final season
of keeping up with the kardashians on e
aired last night and it was pretty good
i mean
we're getting less courtney maybe that's
why i thought it was a good episode but
i literally sat in a few scenes where
she didn't say one thing
i think she probably wasn't even miked
like literally that's crazy um
but it was kind of weird because a big
part of the storyline is actually about
her
on specifically how she kind of impacts
scott and scott's relationship with
different people
and while i am really sad that sofia and
scott didn't work out i feel like at the
end of the day sophia is like just one
of those main character girls like who
deserves a man who can give her full
attention and
of course the situation's not for
everyone um
and so i get that she had to bounce but
i feel like and even though i disapprove
of his relationship with amelia like
amelia's
just thirsty enough to be dating scott
disick that she doesn't mind
that he you know spends six days out a
week with courtney you know yeah that is
a good point
i'm happy for sophia because if like the
relationship wasn't making her happy
then she shouldn't
be in it um and that house they got
malibu was like so
sickening so sickening but also so great
for the filming of this season and i
i don't know why i mean they obviously
did this because of quarantine they
can't go places but it's like a
no-brainer because everyone's just like
popping around the house yeah everyone's
happy to be
at the house so nice and then we just
get all these wonderful scenes
yeah so i think that it is such a great
um
sort of concept to frame the season
through they're also
um showing us a lot of kim's journey to
taking the baby bar and they're teasing
a lot of
things like of her crying saying she
feels like a loser she's going through
stuff and i think they're
trying to make us feel like they're
talking about kanye yeah but i'm pretty
sure
that she failed the baby bar you think
yeah
like almost 100 percent but when she's
crying saying i feel like such a loser
you think oh i don't know i thought i
feel like we reported
i can barely remember but i feel like
she passed the bar and that's when scott
made those kim is my lawyer sweatshirts
but it's not the bar even if she be it's
the baby bar and even if she passes she
doesn't become a lawyer no but like
i feel like she did something like
something good happened
i was under the assumption that she like
fully failed but she said that she
thought she passed
kim kardashian baby bar
i feel like she definitely does not pass
oh my god i really hope that you are
right
because i a hundred percent thought
those scenes were about kanye kim
kardashian passed the bar test
june 2020 hints explained okay this is
like some shady ass website
kim is trying to become a lawyer i might
just give us the answer
did she pass the bar nothing has been
confirmed yet it's looking
likely that kim kardashian did pass her
baby bar as one reddit user pointed out
there's been one major hint by kris
jenner on instagram in june 2020 cookies
momager kim shared pictures of lawyer
themed cookies with kim's face onto some
onto instagram
which seems like a celebration for
something law related or was it the
party last night
right which just celebrated her taking
it kim live tweeted
yesterday's episode with a positive
attitude saying i spend so many hours
studying but it's definitely worth it
when asked if she'd discuss her bar
experience on her new podcast she
responded it's gonna be the best i can't
wait for you guys to tune in
sounds like someone who passed their
baby bar test to us that none of that no
hitc.com i never heard of you but i
don't agree with your logic whatsoever
i hope you are right because as much as
i know they're getting divorced
i actually don't want to watch it play
out on the show because one
it just feels like it just feels wrong
because
kanye doesn't has never participated in
the show it's not fair we never
even saw the good of their marriage it's
not fair that we should only see the bad
really i mean i would like to see it but
i
hear you i would it would make me like
sad and also
maybe a little even upset with him
it just wouldn't be like her at all yeah
so i i'm honestly hoping that they don't
um a majority of the episode was spent
on chris kristen
tristan and chloe um he actually got his
own confessionals and i feel like
we're always talking about tristan we're
never hearing from tristan and he's
actually like
kind of funny like he has a big
personality i'm a big fan of his and
then when cory gave his seal of approval
i was like then i'm in i know but like i
really struggle like
because this whole week they've been
playing like old episodes of kardashians
and there's just like been so many
things tristan has done to like
disrespect chloe like
uh cheating on her while she's pregnant
uh the jordan woods of it all like
i don't know and it feels those are the
things those are the things that i have
in my mind already like are there other
things that
no but like they're so big they're so
big but he has spent
years now no i'm trying to make it right
but it's like what if jordan woods like
for real no but like jordan woods i feel
like is thriving
not as it pertains to the kardashians
i'm saying no she has not been forgiven
at all
yeah and i understand like tristan is
the baby is true's father like
they can't get rid of him if they want
to it just feels like
like like a double standard yeah but i
feel like
i i feel like the kardashians have
forgiven
jordan even if they're not they don't
speak anymore like in their hearts like
everyone has moved on from it
yeah you know i don't know
i don't know if i agree with that i i
feel like everyone because you can't
forgive tristan without forgiving jordan
right but but you're letting tristan
back in of course because he has true
but also like they're gonna have another
baby together he seems to be around he's
at the house in malibu he films like
so like where just where does jordan
land in all of this is my question
i guess we'll truly never know maybe
it's just like
the best for you there's too much has
happened well i do like seeing him and i
feel like
one particular scene that i really liked
was um like chloe's just like she's
gonna do anything to have a baby and i
like admire her so much for it
um when she's talking about surrogacy
she's being so open and then she
literally she breaks the fourth wall
she's like
and you know they say dr wong said that
i have like a 60
chance of miscarrying because of you
know health reasons that i'm not going
to say on camera
and i'm just like so here for her
literally sharing everything and i
really like respected her
candidness yes question for you do you
think that she
is a surrogate right now and it's like
they're expecting it's very possible
i think that they are i actually thought
truesdale needs a sibling she does she
needs a sibling
boy or girl i love tristan's reaction
when chloe said that she wanted to
have another child like that he's been
waiting for that he has been
and they've been through so much and he
i think has put in the time
and done the work and i think that i'm
really happy at the place they're where
they're at and they're also not in a
romantic
relationship they are family and i'm
cautiously optimistic
uh yes i am
optimistic we didn't get enough kris
jenner in the episode and i just really
feel
like she's kind of been like the most
undervalued character
on the show and i just hope we get a big
season of kris jenner like that's
she's in such a good place in her life i
know there's a lot of stuff coming up
between her and caitlyn
also do you see this theory that kaitlyn
jenner is on the master singers
she went home last night spoiler oh
i think yes i heard her i heard a
performance everyone was like it's
caitlyn i'm like oh
a hundred percent yeah it's honestly
like it was a bad cast because
she is such a distinct voice yeah i'm
pretty sure she went home last night
got it um also i what i do think that
the kim
stuff is about next week i think it's
about um
kanye not about the divorce yet but like
when he did his
political campaign um but does that
line up time-wise this summer i think it
does
no he was like running before i don't
know
i mean that had to have been hard on kim
like yeah so i think it's about that
stuff
okay i mean we'll see we'll see but like
i just love them so much like and i'm
really
you know you all you don't know what you
got until it's kind of now i'm just like
watching like being so appreciative
like of not only the memories like i
literally remember being like in our old
bedrooms
with our bunk beds like watching
kardashians like it just goes back so
far
and then all the spin-offs miami and the
highs the lows the chris humphries
and not only that but like you really
see like how at the end of the day
everything that they do is like
so like tied to family and like they
just like ride or die for each other so
hard it's like
you can't help but admire the [ __ ] out
of them yeah i just love them so much
i'm like getting emo now i know and it's
just crazy because like they're going to
be back and we're going to be watching
them but
it's it's a new era by the way the song
i was thinking of that's the other song
from the commercial is called
bang we'll go out with a bag i don't
know that one
oh it's a good commercial not as good as
the sign of the times one though
both good notes different emotions did
you watch kendall and kylie is drunk
get ready with me i did not did you i
did um for some reason it was giving me
like really bad anxiety
um and i'm just like so much more of a
kylie than a kendall like it's crazy and
like
everyone was like can go so crazy like
so funny i'm like i would not want to
get drunk with kendall like
she's so messy like get it together and
before they drank she was like no no
like
i'm so not sloppy like i hold my alcohol
so well and then she's like literally
crying
and she like can't even stand up it was
like were there any good nuggets of info
no
and they did cry over her acne but but
it wasn't about the acne it was actually
just really sweet
i guess when they would like go to
school like kendall would be like so
subconscious and kylie would just like
hyper up she's like you're literally so
beautiful like whatever
and kendall was like that actually like
really meant a lot to me like i used to
like have this anxiety i'm like well
kylie thinks i'm beautiful
and they were crying about that which
was actually really sweet that's really
sweet
um i'm just like not a big kendall girly
like at all
no me me neither and that's that on that
but i i do still plan to watch it i just
completely forgot about it yeah and they
were saying like kendall's been thinking
about starting a youtube channel so that
was like an actually
one of the interesting nuggets okay i
watched her thing with kendall like
some sort of um i watched the thing with
haley bieber
i literally turned off in a minute it
was two of the most boring people i've
ever seen in my life like
and they thought they were like so crazy
for making mac and cheese in their
bathroom
i watched a clip from it where like i
don't even remember what was happening
but they thought it was so funny no
they're just like two girls who think
they're so
crazy but like they ain't you know
um so that's our kardashians recap and
that's like it that's
it wow everyone enjoy this weekend
reminder next week we are remote but we
are back in studio the week after that
so uh take care arrivederci
what was it
yeah yeah it's at the tip of my tongue
or
far thank you guys so much from 13 going
out there
thank you guys so much for listening to
the morning toast the millennial morning
show where we list
where we deliver the fast five stories
that you need to know every monday
through friday on youtube so
if you're watching us on youtube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
as a podcast and where podcasts can be
found so it's spotify it's institute
public video i don't really care about
all the places so wherever you listen to
podcasts find out the morning shows
leave a five star review about how
beautiful
stunning and smart we are we hope you
have an amazing safe weekend
have fun everyone we love you and we'll
see you you'll hear from us on monday
bye goodbye goodbye